hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the park watcher a game
that touts itself as a puzzle game but
from what I've seen in the screenshots
ah I bet my cheap Howie
all right so I can't win this intro
thank you very much I'm just gonna get
into this this is the park watcher it's
a horror game with puzzle elements let's
go blade you have been captured by the
park watcher for one week now find a way
to escape the cellblocks
alley my cheeky hurts so anyway there's
glowy glowy over here what do I do with
that nothing apparently hello okay so
why would I want to leave the grasp of
this amazing park watcher and why is he
called the park watcher if I'm in a Cell
know I do with this Punk take that brick
barrel that's what you get I hit that
sorry what was that
okay oh I'm sure what I'm doing here I
think I'm digging with my bare hands
come on Oh
okay very sorry did i disturb you by
digging a nice hole in the ground and
also why is there blood ear not blood
ear blood here did that do nothing did
not do some there another glowy glow
than they need to break what do i do
what do I do
what am i no no no is that what I wrote
it oh I have a strange feeling Hamill's
sorry I apologize
you'll see using the darkness need to go
away my vision is getting a little
wobbly probably because it's very dark
and I'm afraid of the dark at least his
character is I'm not I'm brave I'm not a
coward baby pants I'm not wandering in
the darkness bed with a family anyway
what am I supposed to do now aren't a
noise can't see a damn thing
did I make a horrible error okay so I
actually just restarted the game because
I think I messed something up unless I'm
supposed to make it dark which I don't
think that I'm supposed to do but I did
anyway so let's just see what happens
now if I need to make it dark and
there's no other way I'm gonna actually
just not have the light again see what
happens okay so what do I do now I throw
a rock at this dirt I just dug up yeah
Rock give me that rock Oh who's that
Oh take that you smarmy bastard no yeah
no okay yeah sorry did not mean to
disturb your box are you resting in
there he's having a grand old time
yeah I don't know what I'm supposed to
do I'm just gonna throw rocks and things
until they work let me hurt
I'm innocent that tells you I didn't
kill those 13 people and a baby
I warned me I killed 15 people but not
13 give me credit where credit's due
Warren Park watcher who wait a minute Oh
is there a switch over there on the wall
over there oh I am so smart oh I'm so
hard
what's this yeah look at me
okay that is ridiculously slow why is
that so slow come on Park watcher is
watching don't you know these things all
right sorry what happened where who what
why why is that read the park Watchers
gonna be mad there's been an escaped
convict a murderer of 13 people and a
baby how dare I cuz I am the crazed but
stabber and in reality I stamped those
butts I'm the one who framed Marga bars
for stabbing those butts when it was
really me okay so there's a cherry ER
couple plants on the ground am I
supposed to go back and get those rocks
oh I need a key
well I'll just search around till I find
said key I'm sure that it'll be glowing
in the docs smari can you stop that I
know there's nothing actually to that
unless there is something to that and
you're just not telling me just yet
which in case will I will deal with it
as it comes my cheek hurts so don't bug
with me okay so I got to find out why
this wall is red over here give me that
ha oh it's not a wall okay this is a
glowy glow from over here
dddd dddd i'm sure nothing bad will
happen to me as i dig in the floor don't
you see I'm gonna bleed up my nails real
good I don't know I'm talking with a
hick accent for summary I think that the
prisoner in here or whoever's captured
by this park warden dude is a bit of a
hillbilly bit of a southern boy bit of a
strangler 15 beau I found it I didn't
even know that was in there cause I
supposed to know I found a key good for
me now can I get out of here now
stop talking in a hillbilly accent
Lissa's move on
I'm sure that my southern audience is
not very enthralled in ability to talk
oh come on I walked right through it if
I knew I could just pass right through
it s oh really I would have done that a
long time ago so what I do now movie
this is dark whoa look at all the
Chinese are those supposed to guide me
why can i not move I'm not moving
what's up am i hitting a wall here
what's going on where am I oh I'm in
darkness I cannot see anything oh sorry
not do that I cannot move all the bits
of light are not getting any closer can
I move please can I move please I'm in
the dark alone I don't want to be here
wanna be anywhere about here okay okay
there's way is that the way I'm supposed
to go or is that the way I came did I
find some am I here ah
dingus damn it damn it blam it Oh am I
supposed to do wait a minute isn't that
the place where I was isn't that the
beginning area huh oh god damn it I was
my only rock how much wood oh oh okay I
got it
mine locales Walker
I swear the shadows on the ground any
better bothering me digging a hole in
the ground stop it
you're nothing you're nothing this
you're just the park Watchers messing
with me now I know there's a thingy over
here yeah who knew that I can throw a
rock and poop 11 oh when it was
supposedly going down oh come on I keep
forgetting that I don't actually need to
wait for this take your digga digga
digga digga I'm a weirdo a weirdo
hillbilly that digs in the ground and I
stab the bud of 13 people 15 people not
a baby I did not do anything to that
baby
no one fainted I may be crazy I may be a
bug stabber
I didn't was that you know how many
people after I made up the butt stabber
story gave me that news story where
there actually was a serial but stabber
like what are the odds there's actually
a but stabber I'm made of a stupid story
about someone who likes to stab butts
why why would you stab butts of all the
things to stab well I mean preferably
you wouldn't stab anything at all okay I
found a key what do I do with this key
type device pretty the way ironic
you're just random aren't you you're not
actually anything I'm gonna regret today
when you're actually something but right
now you are nothing you are nothingness
you had nothing to me maybe I need to
blow out the light for this red one oh
yeah they got Park watcher that's what I
think your place yay
I'm outta here I'm Audi baby climbing up
the side of the ladder I think Oh nose
head oh that was okay
oh it was a one-man developer team and
he's 15 years old okay so that explains
a lot I mean it was a bit repetitive
there with view of the puzzle elements
and it wasn't exactly threatening
because there never was something that
was actually gonna kill me
but either way got to give credit where
credit's due that was not bad I played
some bad games in the past if you want
to see those bad games check the
annotations over there there's but
people have made some games that's all I
gotta say about that but this was not
bad show the guys some love a link to
the games in the description below thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
oh well that's just too bad